hi my name is Abu Bakr Salim I play bike
in Assassin's Creed origins I auditioned
for it through my acting agent thinking
that it was a animated TV series it was
advertising animated TV series and with
motion capture and yes so when - it was
like a standard audition going to the
room had sides did my lines and then got
to the second round and then at the
second round they told me it was for a
video game for Assassin's Creed 2 which
I lost my mind and and where we they
ended up saying that okay so because
it's for because it's promotion captions
because it's for the video game the way
that they did the audition and the way
that they filmed the audition was that
they used a bigger space so there wasn't
any type tight shot so there wasn't any
sitting down or standing it was they
wanted to see me move and I remember
that process being really different to
to other to other auditions because
normally you're just sitting down in
there still and it's all within the face
whereas in this one specifically they
wanted your body and yes that was that
was how I got into it really yeah there
is this huge like you know realm of
possibilities of because you've got to
think of the player I think there's a
lot of you know you've got to really
think of you know the player choices and
you've got to be able to perform you
know with the same intensity depending
on what the player chooses and so you
know there's a lot more kind of there's
a lot more stories you know there's a
lot more branching off whereas you know
where's tip film and TV is quite linear
you know video game it's very much like
a tree it could branch down this way it
could branch the other way or you know
so you've got all these other choices
that you've got to play with and and
it's a challenge it is a challenge and
but at the same time it's so much fun
you know so it is so liberating because
it is like it is that it goes back to
that feeling of okay let's imagine that
we are over here or let's imagine we
made this choice so you've got all these
different things to play with so this is
the thing right so I remember getting
getting the getting the fact that it was
a video game and thinking that this is a
video game character completely made-up
and I remember thinking okay I could
either play this guy as a stereotypical
superhero video game character who does
you know one thing and becomes a
or I could see him as a human being and
I think what is so exciting and
fascinating about videogames and
nowadays anyway is that the stories in
which we are which they which were being
given which were you know being fed to
us as players are very human stories are
very relatable stories and so yeah the
way I kind of the way I approach biock
was as a man first as a human being who
is in these circumstances which are
tough but at the same time you know it's
not that he is the superhero of the day
he's just a man going through these
through these events so yeah so it
that's the kind of where I went to
approach it I did a lot of research in
ancient Egypt I tried to read as much as
I could I mean we were very hands-on
with the team as well the historians of
you know do be soft and they kind of you
know they were there telling us about
you know the history of ancient Egypt
and you know when it came to dialects
and stuff it was because again we've got
no recordings of dialects we had to sort
of not necessarily make it up but we had
to create something that the player
could you know could sort of relate to
but at the same time keep them immersed
but when it came to actually you know
going through you know different sort of
rituals and you know you know different
you know language and dialects and all
this sort of stuff it was you know they
are you know we have lots of ancient
Egyptian words that we use Egyptian
words even that we use in the game you
know to keep it to keep that flavor
there came to approach them you know
bringing the character alive again like
different techniques than that like
again it's all it's it's it's like
creating a character for TV or film you
know it's it's it's you start at you
start at the you know the beginning
where it's like okay what's his
motivation and then you drive from there
and then you add the historical element
on top of that and it just yet begins to
form motion capture is so it's so
different to theater and film it's like
a weird hybrid actually I personally
found it incredibly liberating and and
so freeing think Andy Serkis says it's
like the purest form of acting and I can
see that because you know usually you
know on film and TV and even you know
theater you get so you get props you
know you've got the costume
got some form something to kind of
anchor yourself to to be like okay I am
in the 1920s or I am in the future
whereas in motion-capture you've got
none of that you've got just the suit
yourself
these weird balls dots on your face a
huge helmet with a camera and lights and
it's you know you've got to imagine
yourself being in this hot desert and
you know where actually you're in a
warehouse with 200 cameras flashing blue
lights at you
you know and it's you've got to really
imagine you've got to really imagine
that the person you know opposite you is
this really evil enemy decked out in all
this crazy armor you've got to imagine
you're holding a sword which is a stick
or a shield which is a dustbin lid you
know you've got to imagine all these
things and it's it is it's liberating
and freeing because this is the stuff
that you did as kids this is why you
kind of why I got into acting anyway
it's playing all these stories so yeah
it is it is incredibly liberating and
and and very challenging and different
but so much fun I'd say the most
difficult probably was the turnover of
scenes that we had to do you know we
were we were doing 15 scenes a day and
you know there was a lot of lines to
learn because it is a video game is
massive you know massive amounts of
dialogue so yeah there was a lot of that
going on that was quite challenging but
then you get into a rhythm of it and you
know what was so great about working on
Assassin's Creed with Ubisoft is that
they still allowed you time to play and
you could really play and because of you
know the cameras were all set everything
was kind of you know there wasn't there
wasn't time and changing you know
positions of camera and not all angles
because that's all done in the editing
room so there was a lot of there was
still a lot of time to play but as an
actor was very hard to let you know get
the script the next day track down the
story of where it's you know words where
it is learn the lines and then do it you
know that was that was quite a challenge
oh man I mean yeah I mean tons of fun
and the fact that you know the team were
poor so there's so much there unless
another thing there was so much loving
in the actual team itself that it felt
like it felt it felt it just felt easy
in a way you know everything you know it
just it felt quite there was a flow to
it
there was a fluidity to it which was
brilliant
I think there is so much to mine from
that way of storytelling I think video
games is I mean it was my way and I mean
I remember as a kid I you know I I was
dyslexic I couldn't read books you know
TV shows and films I didn't really
connect to because I wasn't any person I
could really connect to but video games
because it is so interactive and and it
involves you and you know in the story
and going on this journey with this
character you know it was it was it was
just so it was it was so cool to you
know to kind of get involved in so I
loved the idea of being able to tell a
story that way through a videogame
through someone can you know going on
this journey with me
interactively spending eight you know
hundreds of hours with me
you know seeing this world that has been
created by you know these people who
really love what they're doing and yeah
I think I definitely want to want to
venture more into that and see more into
that and play more into that absolutely
the one thing that was kind of that I've
tried to really do is just focus on my
own journey not compare myself to other
you know my peers and just try and just
do what I love and kind of keep that
love going and keep fighting and keep
going because it is tough it's it's me
you know there's the I could be working
now I could be doing these great
interviews now and then I could you know
in a month's time I'd be at home to live
my films probably playing my game but
like it's like it's a you know it can
shift and change so quickly but I think
it there is that if you really want to
do it and you know you can you really
feel like this is this is this is for me
just keep going
it'll happen it will happen because you
know the more you kind of give off to
the universe it will give it back in
some way shape and form
so yeah just keep going
you
[Music]